on apprend qu'un enfant de 10 ans fait
partie des quatre personnes décédées
dans ce bombardement à Cléry il y a
jusqu'à présent il y a plus de 40
blessés les recherches continuent dans
les décombres c'est frappe elles ont
touché un immeuble résidentiel un
institut d'éducation dans la ville de
crédits Rivery je rappelle que c'est la
ville natale du président voulait dire
Zelenski c'est une ville qui a déjà été
touchée très lourdement notamment en
cours de l'hiver lorsque les
infrastructures électriques du pays
était visé ce ne sont pas les seules
frappes russes des dernières 24 heures
puisque la nuit dernière la ville de
harkif a également été visée avec des
missiles S300 alors ils sont tirés vous
savez harki fait seulement à 30 km de la
frontière avec le crâne donc ces
missiles sont tirés assez rapidement il
n'y a pas le temps d'avoir les alertes
donc souvent ça fait beaucoup de
dommages des frappes également de
roquettes cette fois sur la ville de
Helson une personne est déc édée et puis
ici à cramator ce qu'une zone
industrielle a été visée plusieurs
bâtiments ont été détruits on a entendu
au cours de la nuit peu après minuit
trois trois explosions 3 très grosses
explosions donc ici à cramators donc
c'est frappe qui continue tous les jours
sur le territoire ukrainien